I love her like I loved her before we
did Hollywood Hollywood what Hollywood
we didn't do Hollywood game night it was
Hollywood game night and it was super
fun I loved her before them but I will
say before we get to my love of
peppermint and aeleus and all things you
do um use that Meryl how is she is she
great
I mean I met her brief I don't know her
okay
you met her and you're famous and your
movies and she's famous in the movies
it's you're kind of the same yeah we're
kind of the same yeah um no I was I did
a play on with Kevin Kline we did cyrano
love him yes Sophie's Choice yes and
they were old pals and every night he he
didn't want to know who was in the
audience and every night he would say I
think I heard Meryl laughs did you hear
Meryl Merrill's out there I'm sure and
then the night that she came back we
were like she's in here you're finally
here oh my god but she was you know
she's she's a person yeah no I'm totally
normal human that's why I think I love
her so much because she doesn't like
she's like she's mom Frank yeah like
normal mom that's what yeah I'm obsessed
with her I'm obsessive do you love about
you
you have no chill
[Laughter]
I literally run like yes all the time
you make me seem calm like I feel like a
very zen vibe because I'm hacking into
your yang and it's I feel like it really
worked I know I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not going to stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this